this is a production of Cornell
University
well great thanks everyone done
hopefully you're enjoying enjoying the
day it's been really wonderful and a lot
to learn and take in I think Tom kill
sir and I are the only two in this
session and we're gonna be talking about
managing cover crops for forage and I
will say at least I believe Tom and I
are both in some ways talking mostly
about feeding cattle and some of you may
have questions about other livestock and
maybe we can answer that and maybe
someone else here in this room can
answer those questions too so I told Tom
I would try to give an introduction to
what he was gonna say so here we go
one of the things that I feel like
really helped cover crops take off
pretty quickly
no let's rephrase that not quickly but
once people realized well once people
started cooking finally after how many
years we kept trying to get them to do
it Sandra I think once people realize
that they could also actually use those
cover crops as a feed source
you know the adoption rate really
skyrocketed for us anyway in Vermont and
I'm not Shh you know some of the work
that Tom did that we've done as well
people really started to look at cover
crops as more than a cover crop not the
cover crops aren't important but I think
you know many of the farmers we work
with feed and making sure you have
enough feed and high-quality feed to
feed those animals that are producing
the milk or the meat I mean that's your
top priority and really everything else
comes after that even though all the
other components managing the soil all
these things are obviously critical to
getting high-quality feed you know
everything sort of stocks that making
sure those cows can give milk you know
at least in Vermont so you know selling
cover crops has been a difficult you
know sell but again once people realize
that there was an
opportunity to gain more than just a pat
on the back things really took off and I
personally worked with a number of
organic dairy so I'll talk about grazing
a little bit and Tom will talk more
about stored feed I personally saw a lot
of organic dairy farmers in particular
starting to plant cover crops as they
were thinking about rotations to
actually extend their grazing season and
that's where I really started to think
about boy maybe we could get all of our
other dairy farms to think about this
too so I mean we've heard enough about
all the great things that cover crops do
so I'm not going to spend my time
talking about that but one of the things
that we saw early on when we first
started looking at double cropping John
Jemison and I and a few others from the
University of Maine had this project
funded through the IPM Center to look at
double cropping I think that was in like
2009 or 2010 and it was in organic
systems but this is the same in
conventional systems what we really saw
was one of the benefits to doing it was
just reduced weed pressure there were a
lot less weeds in the corn following a
harvest of a cover crop and so that was
a real benefit on top of the soil
quality benefits on top of the fact that
people were getting feed especially in
an organic system having a lot less weed
pressure was another major benefit to
the system alright so back to how we're
working with farmers on thinking about
cover cropping and this is where I feel
like we still have a lot of work to do
but you know when a farmer starts
thinking about growing crops he doesn't
start thinking about that the day he
goes out with this planter or his
harvester he's thinking about that and
planning for that all the time through
the whole season it's not just something
like I'll have to all have time to make
that feed today you know he's really
planning this whole system out and what
we really want farmers to do is actually
plan for cover cropping well before the
that they actually do it and especially
if you're thinking about using cover
crops for feed you need to plan for that
okay because they really need to be
planted at a certain time at the right
seeding rate the type of cover crop you
may choose will change depending on what
you're feeding or when you want to
harvest it herbicide programs the
maturity of your corn these are all
things that you need to plan for to be
able to harvest a cover crop for feed so
we're really looking at you know the
entire year and planning that out and
having cover crops be an actual part of
your crop plan now for those of us that
are you know researchers scientists you
know working whatever we're doing this
seems like something that we would just
do but it really hasn't been that way
you know cover crops have not actually
been a part of somebody's cropping plan
and that's changing but we're continuing
to encourage that so that we're more
successful alright so one of the first
pieces that we've been trying to
consider for many years now I almost
feel like a broken record but you're a
new audience so you haven't heard me say
this is that we've been really trying to
get farmers to grow shorter season corn
to be able to get those cover crops
planted more timely now that's been a
really hard sell it's changed a lot over
the last 10 years since I started
talking about this people are shifting
away from really long season corn but
I've collected the same data for 14
years and it is true that the relative
maturity of the corn is not a good
indicator of top performance that a
short season corn can often outperform a
long season corn and it's really more
dependent upon variety selection and
less you know dependent on the relative
maturity which is the value of having
University corn variety trial
experiments and Cornell I know just
started doing theirs again and we're
partnering with them but really being
able to see a lot of different varieties
across a lot of different maturities
is important because we not only want
we not only want the farmer to choose
you know a 98 day mature relative
maturity variety but we want them to
choose the best one so that the yield is
as high as that 108 day variety that
they used to grow okay so why here's
just an example but why why do we want
farmers to plant shorter season corn
so they harvest it earlier and they're
able to plant the cover crop at the time
that's best for the cover crop okay
so whether you're growing it for feed or
just you know not shouldn't I do does a
cover crop as a cover crop timing of
planting is very important and so this
is data from Vermont compiled over many
years but you can see the relative
maturity these are all different
varieties and then these are the
planting dates so we tried to plant the
longer season corn a bit earlier than
the shorter season corn but you can see
when we're planning corn that's kind of
in this 80 day range to early 90 day
range we can be harvesting that in most
years in early September that gives us
plenty of time to get a cover crop in
maybe more time than the farmer I
shouldn't say more time than they want
but even planning these what we would
call in Vermont midseason varieties buys
us enough time to get a good cover crop
established when we get into these late
maturing hybrids and actually in Vermont
you know we were harvesting corn into
November this year I finished chopping I
think like two weeks ago those who are
very late season varieties now in most
years you really want to be getting your
corn chopped by this time and getting
that cover crop in the ground so we've
really been promoting shortening that
maturity and I think Tom will talk about
that too no I don't think so
I think it's random yep
okay and then just average if we average
the harvest dates so 92 to 98 day corn
on average is harvest around
mid-september where our hundred and two
208 day corn this is in Vermont again
you know is is closer to the end of
September into October in most years hey
alright so the next thing we're really
trying to get people to focus on is
planning date and especially if you
really want to have a nice stand of
forage right you want to make sure it's
planted timely so that it has time to
grow a bit tiller and produce a lot of
biomass the next year so we've done
years of planting date studies and you
can see dry matter yield this is the
following year when this is winter rye
is planted at different dates okay so
you know you can maximize dry matter
yield the second year by planting
earlier okay now this is something a lot
of people observe but don't really
understand is that small grains tiller
so you have one plant and then from that
one seed they make multiple plants and
you can observe this in the field when
you plant a winter rye cover crop and
you see those single spikelets come out
of the ground and then you go back
hopefully you know two three weeks later
probably three weeks later a month later
and you see the whole areas filled in
you don't see bare ground anymore okay
now if you plant too late if you're
planting in October let's say hey what
ends up happening is you just see those
spike lights and you say oh I have a
really thin stand this year because it
didn't have enough time to tiller and
actually fill in okay so that's bad from
an environmental perspective but also
from a forage perspective because if you
don't get any tillering you have a lot
less yield the next year so that's part
of the importance of planting timely so
that you can reduce your seeding rate
for one thing okay and you make up for
that by getting more tillering and then
more yield the next year and then of
course you have better ground cover more
roots
all of those positive benefits okay so
tillering can account for almost 60% of
the yield so it's really important and
it's only gonna tell her if it's planted
timely okay so you need to get the corn
harvested get the cover crop on on time
okay and get it give it enough time to
actually grow and tiller and fill it all
right so seeding rate and we've had this
conversation over and over and over
again and we've gone up on seeding rates
down on seeding rates often times if
we're planning for forage we do tend to
plant at higher seeding rates than if
we're just cover cropping now in Vermont
you know we recommend at this point I
think we're at 75 pounds Sandra if it's
seated on time because that's 75 pounds
really you should get enough tillering
to fill in but often many of our farmers
will bump those seeding rates up to get
more biomass for forage okay now if
you're trying to kill them kill that
cover crop through tillage next year you
likely don't want all of that biomass so
it makes sense to have a slightly lower
seeding rate okay but if you're trying
to maximize biomass you may want to
increase that seeding rate
make sure it's planted on time right and
then you have a good forage stand now if
you start thinking about this as a
forage and not just a cover crop okay a
lot of people don't put as much effort
into their cover crops as they should
people put a lot of effort into growing
crops and so what we're trying to do is
get people to put as much effort into
this crop as they do their other crops
alright
so variety selection these are three
common there's also winter barley but
that's not quite as common because it
doesn't overwinter very well in Vermont
it probably does here but most farmers
are growing rye triticale or wheat as a
forage crop and the thing that I want
you to notice is dry matter yields this
is actually from this year so dry matter
yields and time harvest ok so winter rye
we were getting about two tons of
yield and this was harvested in the boot
stage hey and it was harvested the 23rd
of May so if you're trying to plant corn
after this I think most farmers want
that to come off as soon as possible
so that then they can go in and plant
their corn right now you can see for us
triticale was about a week later and
then we was right around the same time
now Tom saw opposite of what we saw he
saw lower yields with wheat I think you
said and higher yields with the other
crops but whatever variety we grew and I
think it was a four inch week so I don't
remember the exact varieties I don't see
Sarah here she worked on the project
Samantha here no she's not here either
okay so I mean just really I think for
most farmers this is what's really
important to them as well as the yields
but being able to get it off timely
enough have enough time to get the corn
crop in or whatever other crop they may
be growing after that may not be corn
may be soybeans may be something else
okay mmm so variety selection is
important here's some other types of
grains that we looked at and also
varieties so here's here on rye this is
a variety not stated triticale try Cal
zero nine nine one four one here's a
winner barley and then two types of
wheat and Spell okay now you can see the
difference in yields from the different
forage types and varieties but again I
think the the important thing for many
farmers here is right here
when are we harvesting this stuff hey so
with our here on rye that was harvested
about the same time as this triticale
variety not stated again right around
the third week of May and then
everything else was was after that and I
think what was really interesting is
that these different triticale varieties
are heading out at different times so
again just like we select varieties of
corn if we're going to grow some of
these different cover crop
for feed then managing variety selection
again will become really important
especially if we're trying to get that
feed harvested by the third week of May
we don't want to pick a late season
triticale to plant and end up not
harvesting until June right and then you
can see spelt with much later and then
this year you know wheat was late as
well these would have all been planted
like third week of September in the fall
yeah no and I think that you know that's
the interesting thing is that when
they're harvested early so whether it's
grazed or really probably up to the boot
stage we don't see a lot of difference
between species and also varieties but
as they begin to mature more those
varietal differences and also species
differences really start to show to show
but early on they don't show as much yes
exactly
yep okay so nitrogen management Tom will
talk about this as well but basically we
do see a response to fertilizing these
winter forages in some cases and I think
just to take home messages would you
grow any other crop without considering
its nutrient needs and really that's
what you need to think about you know
and sometimes we'll see a yield response
from adding additional nitrogen
sometimes we won't but really what you
need to do is figure out what its
nutrient needs are and understand if
you're meeting those correct and really
basically what we do for the most part
is plant the cover crop and hope it
grows hay but if you're growing it as a
crop you have a very different
perspective and you wouldn't just throw
a crop out there without even thinking
about what it needed to eat and so it's
no different with this this was spring
applied yep but you know like what we
what we generally see is if the
nomen or addition to the system you're
gonna need fertility right that just
makes sense with men or whether or not
you need additional fertility that
depends okay and I think Tom will talk
about that more and same kind of thing
once you start growing two crops in a
season you need to be thinking about
what those two crops need hey not just
your main season crop and and we see
farmers get into trouble with this all
the time they're double cropping here's
the crop nitrogen removal rate for just
a standard double crop you're looking at
an removal rate almost you know over two
hundred and fifty pounds
okay and most people are only
fertilizing for their corn and what ends
up happening is you know this cereal is
taking out almost a hundred pounds of
nitrogen and so what ends up happening
is their corn needs a lot more to eat
and if they haven't planned for that
they can run into a lot of trouble okay
it's caught a lot of people by surprise
where they'll take a PS NT and they get
back the results and it's twice what
they would normally do is this a benefit
or not you know growing this as a feed
okay I think Tom we'll talk about the
economics so this is staged harvest
vegetative boot milk soft dough
different times that you can harvest the
forage all with different quality
analysis and all with different yields
and really you know when you choose to
harvest this completely in your ball
court as a farmer what are you looking
for you need pasture you need feed you
need heifer feed the weather wasn't any
good so you ended up here instead of
here you know all those things happen
but as Tom just mentioned stage of
harvest has more impact on quality than
anything else okay
and this is net energy of lactation for
the different harvest stages did you
give me a 5 minute already and I didn't
see you
you didn't wave oh okay it's like man
don't be so subtle you know let's get up
here okay and
you know so again this is vegetative any
else and you can see its its highest
with a vegetative it starts to move down
when you get into the milk stage it's
actually the lowest and then it begins
to go up again as you get to the soft
dough stage because you're making grain
right you're making energy at that point
so the worst time really to harvest is
in the milk stage okay
touch on grazing a little bit we've done
a lot of studies looking at grazing
winter forages so this is in West
Swanton and you can just see cows have
graze this versus not so you can see
they just really like to trim off the
top leafy part what we've seen over the
years of doing this work is that it's a
nice way to get the cows out onto
pasture 1 to 2 weeks before you would
put them out on standard perennial
forage pasture now this obviously is
dependent on the year but in the study
that we conducted in Wes wantin you can
see we almost had a ton of dry matter by
the 3rd of May and this farm doesn't
normally put their cows out to pasture
until about the 14th 15th of May and
what they what we got off the pasture
that first graze you know was a small
fraction of what we had from grazing the
cool season forage so before they even
put the cows out on their normal patch
tour they were able to get about a ton
of dry matter and then start their
normal grazing system season for people
that graze and want to get those animals
out of the barn as soon as possible in
the spring this is a really nice system
to do that it also produces very very
high-quality feed and and it's actually
in some ways it seems to be a bit more
balanced than the perennial pasture
perennial pasture and the spring tends
to be very very high in protein the
winter cereals aren't quite as high so
the cows actually respond quite nicely
to the winter forage and produce a lot
of milk according to the farmers I work
with and I'll just end on forage
brassicas because these have become
popular and cover crop mixes but are
also very popular for grazing and
another crop that we've done a lot of
work looking at planning dates and
yields
I think really what we found over the
years is planning a forage Brassica by
mid-august is ideal to get enough
biomass to be able to graze kind of end
of October into early November okay
so don't start thinking about planning
your Forge Brassica September first
even though intuitively that's what you
would think so I think I'm probably out
of time so I'll end on that that's just
a system that one of our farmers uses
and I'll turn it over to Tom kill sir Oh
okey-dokey
yes
you mean shorter season vegetables well
I think you Altima on a team every crop
up with a cover crop system but and
there are vegetable producers in the
storm I guess I'm one of those to
actually own a vegetable farm but um you
know I think generally at least on our
vegetable farm it's very diverse and we
have crops you know coming in and out
all the time and so we're really
planning cover cropping for each one of
those particular vegetables you know
it's a really different system and I
don't know you know Pete you want to say
anything about what you do but I find
that we're cover cropping almost all
year long in our vegetable farm not just
at a particular time like many dairy
farms so it's pretty different but yeah
that works really good we have not done
that but we've tried to into rolled down
stock cover crop in didn't work so well
yes right yes yep exactly yes and so
what you're talking about is planning
thank you but no you're you're
absolutely right looking at the system
and saying this will fit well here and
the you know this is my best land I want
to do this here ya know
I got the win with it by these Weller
right too far yes yeah yeah I think
that's a good point I think what we find
now is that even though people watch you
know it'd be nice to wait a little bit
here's our time and we're just going and
it may be a little less yield but that's
okay you know yeah it's a trade-off and
I think that's for at least the farmers
I've been working with and it's probably
the same with you you know it's also
given farmers another way to manage that
cover crop in the spring if it does get
a little height of them harder to burn
down harder to plow under or whatever
they're doing just I'm gonna take it a
speed and we saw a lot of that this year
with the weather that we had in Vermont
people
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu